today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens and it's a wonderful
daily blend of vitamins and minerals
ag-1 by athletic greens is a
comprehensive all-in-one greens powder
engineered to fill the nutritional gaps
in your diet and support your body's
nutritional needs across four pillars of
health gut health immune support energy
and recovery it's packed with 75
vitamins and minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients combining the
perfect amount of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jump start your
daily routine you'd be hard-pressed to
find a more comprehensive powder or
supplement on the market right now now
as you guys know i'm not exactly a
fitness youtuber but i do like to eat
right and take care of myself and ag-1
is that comprehensive nutrition
supplement that i know is going to
account for any holes that i might have
in my diet take one scoop out of the tin
where i keep my ag-1 pop it in this
water bottle shake it up and i typically
have this in the morning with my coffee
it tastes good it's kind of sweet but it
doesn't really contain i think it's got
less than one gram of sugar per serving
but it still tastes great plus by
drinking this i know it's filling all
those gaps in my diet which is nice plus
ag-1 is gluten-free dairy-free
paleo-vegan keto low-allergen and
low-calorie yes less than 1 gram of
sugar per serving 81 is the perfect
dietary supplement regimen so if this
sounds like the supplement you've been
looking for then you can grab your own
immunity bundle which gives you five of
these free travel packs and a year's
supply of vitamin d as a bonus with your
first purchase athleticgreens.com
forward slash biographics again year
supply vitamin d five free travel packs
athletic greens.com forward slash
biographics or just click the link in
the description below and now today's
video
king henry v too famous to live long
england never lost a king of so much
worse those are the immortal words of
william shakespeare used to describe our
subject in today's video king henry v
had a short life and an even shorter
reign so why is he remembered as one of
england's greatest monarchs three simple
words battle of agincourt widely
considered one of england's greatest
victories against its perennial enemy
france it turned the tide in the hundred
years war and poised henry to become the
dual monarch of both nations whether or
not this actually happens well let's
find out as we explore the life and the
reign of henry v
henry was born at monmouth castle in the
welsh town of the same name hence why
he's also commonly known as henry of
monmouth strangely enough nobody's
really sure when he was born although we
know that he eventually became king he
was not in the line of succession at
first so nobody bothered to record his
birth in the official records the two
most frequently used dates are september
16th 1386 and august 9 1387. henry was
the eldest of six children to henry
bollingbrook and mary debohan his mother
died in 1394 after giving birth to her
final child while his father took the
throne of england by force from his
cousin richard ii and became king henry
iv in 1399. once his father ascended to
the throne he named henry of monmouth
isaiah and granted him several titles
such as prince of wales and duke of
lancaster although he did not expect it
henry embraced his new role considering
it his destiny to one day rule over
england and conquer france he was
enthusiastic when it came to learning
all aspects of government but he was
absolutely enthralled
when it came to military matters that
being said he was still a young man one
with absolute wealth power and privilege
and he'd like to use them to his
advantage when it came to letting his
hair down several medieval sources
described henry as being somewhat of a
party boy in his youth or an assidious
cultivator of lasciviousness to use
contemporary parlance however it seems
that he got over his wild teenage phase
pretty fast by the time he ascended to
the throne he was better known for his
piety than his partying from a young age
it became clear that henry was a skilled
warrior and commander his father king
henry iv not only encouraged his son's
interest in all things military but
practically demanded it he knew that all
the books and training in the world were
no substitute for the real thing so he
thrust his son into the heat of battle
from an early age this was partially
done out of necessity since king henry
iv had to contend with several
rebellions during his reign and he
needed all the good commanders that he
could get his hands on prince henry of
monmouth distinguished himself at the
battle of shrewsbury in 1403 when he was
only 16 years old against his former
guardian and teacher sir henry hotspur
percy although hotspur originally been
an ally of henry iv and helped him seize
power from richard ii he eventually
rebelled and managed to amass a large
army of people who wanted the king gone
from the throne the battle turned into a
decisive victory for king henry iv after
hotspur was killed in battle but the
king almost lost his heir when prince
henry of monmouth was injured in battle
and this wasn't any paper cut either the
16 year old henry nearly died after
being shot in the head with a freaking
arrow when he was brought to the
hospital henry still had the arrow
embedded deep in his skull but he made a
miraculous recovery thanks to the royal
surgeon john bradmore and as a unique
treat bradmore not only managed to save
the prince's life but also wrote a
treatise detailing his treatment which
still survives to this day here is how
the surgeon described the ordeal the sun
in air was struck by an arrow next to
his nose on the left side during the
battle of shrewsbury the arrow entered
at an angle and the head of the
aforesaid arrow remained in the
furthermost part of the bone of the
skull for the depth of six inches first
i made small probes from the pith of an
elder well dried and well stitched in
putrefied linen the length of the wound
these probes were infused with rose
honey and after that i made larger and
longer probes so that i continued to
always enlarge these probes until i had
the width and depth of the wound as i
wished and after i prepared a new some
tongs small and hollow and with these
the width of an arrow i put these tongs
in at an angle in the same way as the
arrow had first entered then placed the
screw in the center and finally the
tongs entered the socket of the
arrowhead then by moving it to and fro
little by little i extracted the
arrowhead and then i cleansed the wound
with a syringe full of white wine and
placed in new probes made of wads of
flax soaked in a cleansing ointment and
from the second day i shortened the said
wads every two days and thus within 20
days the wound was perfectly well
cleansed and afterwards i regenerated
the flesh with a dark ointment and note
that i always anointed him on the neck
every day in the morning and evening
with anointment to soothe the muscles
and placed a hot plaster on top on
account of fear of spasm which was my
greatest fear and thus thanks to god it
was perfectly cured
[Music]
as you might imagine taking an arrow to
the face in the middle of a battle and
living to talk about it earned henry
some serious bragging rights with his
soldiers this was his first fight and
already the prince developed a
reputation as a mighty warrior even with
the
dorky bowl haircut that he tended to
sport and it didn't take long before
prince henry was back in the saddle both
figuratively and literally ready to take
part in his next conflict this one
wasn't so easily solved though in 1400
the welsh leader owen glinder instigated
to revolt with the goal of ending
english rule in wales he turned into a
formidable foe who kept king henry iv
busy for years to come and in a way even
bested him as he sapped all the energy
from the english king who felt his body
begin to fail him even though he was
still in his late 30s as a result of
this henry of monmouth started taking a
more active role in his father's
government aided by his uncles with free
reign the prince decided to switch
tactics when it came to dealing with
glinder instead of the traditional raids
and skirmishes he adopted a war of
attrition by setting up garrisons in
strategic locations to cut off his
enemy's supply routes this forced the
welsh leader to retreat into his main
strongholds which henry then attacked
with siege weapons meanwhile he also
offered pardons to glinder's allies many
of which took them when they saw the
tide turning against them in 1409
glinder lost his last bastion of safety
harlech castle and was forced to retreat
into the mountains from there he
conducted the occasional raid but he
wasn't a serious threat anymore owen
glinder disappeared completely from the
historical record in 1412 and his
ultimate fate remains a mystery it's
said that only his direct descendants
know the location of his final resting
place and they're not in a sharing mood
as far as henry of monmouth was
concerned he impressed a lot of people
with his military and ministerial skills
despite his young age by 1410 the prince
had become the de facto ruler of the
country as the commander of the royal
council but he soon found himself at
odds with his father the two of them
disagreed over policies specifically
when it came to france and although the
prince had his supporters his father was
still the king and his word was final
fed up with his son's eager and
religious nature king henry iv dismissed
him from the council entirely in 1411.
however he did not take any more drastic
steps such as naming a new air this
meant that for the prince it simply
became a waiting game
one that didn't take very long on march
20th 1413 henry iv's unknown affliction
finally claimed his life after years of
poor health the following months henry v
was crowned the new king of england
[Music]
now that henry was the man in charge he
adopted a conciliatory approach let
bygones be bygones he thought as he
wanted to rule over a united nation and
also move away from his father's legacy
as many regarded him as a bit of a
tyrant henry restored titles and
properties to many noblemen who had been
dispossessed by his father chief among
them edmund mortimer who had been
imprisoned for allying himself with
henry hotspur percy mortimer had been
heir presumptive to king richard ii so
he would have ruled england if henry iv
had not taken power by force even now he
still had the second strongest claim to
the throne after henry v so it was a big
gamble on behalf of the new king to
release edmund mortimer from prison let
alone restore his old authority
fortunately for henry the gamble paid
off mortimer knew not to bite the hand
that fend him instead of fighting again
over the top position and possibly dying
or ending up in prison once more
mortimer's okay with playing second
fiddle and became one of henry's most
trusted counselors he remained loyal
even after the king's death and served
part of the regency council to henry's
infant's son who became the new king of
course not everyone was a fan of henry v
as is often the case when a new ruler
takes power especially one so young
there are people who see it as an
opportunity to sow the seeds of chaos
thinking that the unestablished
inexperienced king will be a bit of a
pushover there are two such instances
during henry's reign that we should
cover before getting to his shenanigans
in france first there were the lollards
a recent religious movement initiated by
theologian john wycliffe a few decades
earlier up until henry's reign they were
mostly tolerated but he felt they were
starting to gain too much traction so he
wanted to stop their momentum by
arresting some of their more prominent
members instead the lollards decided to
fight back and an uprising took place in
1414 led by one of henry's closest
friends sir john old castle previously
the king had even stayed old castle's
execution when he had been sentenced to
death for heresy but for the night his
beliefs trumped his friendship with the
king yet a few hundred conspirators
tried to sneak into henry's palace in
disguise but their poorly planned plot
had already been uncovered by the king's
spies and they proved no match for the
troops waiting for them old carson
himself managed to escape while his
co-conspirators were all hanged or
burned at the stake but his freedom was
only temporary three years later old
castle was captured and executed by
being burned alive
over a slow fire
lovely the other conspiracy against
henry v took place in 1414 and was known
as the southampton plot or the cambridge
plot named after its main instigator
richard of coinsborough third earl of
cambridge he alongside lord scrope and
sir thomas gray were noblemen still
loyal to the former king richard ii who
believed that his heir the
aforementioned edmond mortimer was the
rightful king of england their plan was
to assassinate henry thus paving the way
for mortimer to claim the throne they
didn't get a chance to establish how
they were actually going to do this
because their little intrigue was soon
exposed to the king by none other than
edmund morton himself as we said the
former heir had consigned himself to the
role of sidekick as soon as he was
informed of the plot he was like i want
nothing to do with this you people are
going to get me killed so he went
straight to the king and told him
everything swearing that he had nothing
to do with it fortunately for him the
king believed him as far as the other
three were concerned though despite
calls for clemency it was
off with their heads now the matters in
england had been settled henry v was
finally able to do what he'd always been
wanting to do ever since he was still a
counselor for his father
invade france
[Music]
henry's war against france was part of
the larger conflict between the two
nations known as the hundred years war
which despite his name actually went on
for 116 years it also wasn't one
continuous fight but rather a series of
wars separated by truces when henry
invaded france in 1415 there had been
peace between the two sides for over 25
years ever since the time of his
grandfather john of gaunt who also spent
most of his adult life fighting the
french the whole affair kicked off
thanks to henry's great-grandfather king
edward iii of england who said in 1340
that he had the rightful claim to the
french throne this was the kind of
complicated and incestuous web of
bloodlines that the european royals were
really good at weaving but the gist of
it was that edward iii had been the
closest male relative to the deceased
french king but he was related through
his maternal line the french however
wanted someone related through a male
bloodline so instead they chose philip
vi as their new king of france ever
since then the english kings who
followed edward iii gave themselves the
unofficial title of king of france just
to signify that they had not abandoned
their claim and that the guy who
actually ruled france was just keeping
the throne warm for them when henry v
took power he decided that he didn't
want his title to be merely honorific so
once matters were settled in england he
gathered his army and crossed the
channel in 1415. his first target was
the port town of harfleur it was a small
but important settlement so it was
heavily fortified and was able to
withstand the english siege for over a
month before its inevitable surrender on
september 22 despite being a military
loss the siege of har floor was a boon
for the french the starters gave the
french king charles the sixth time to
muster his troops but it also allowed a
deadly wave of dysentery to spread and
wreak havoc through the english ranks
casualty estimates are all over the map
but they could have totaled a maximum of
5 000 soldiers from both disease and
fighting considering that henry's
initial army was slightly over 11 000
troops that meant that he probably lost
at least a third up to almost half of
his army just besieging this little town
all of a sudden henry's dream of
conquering france seemed dead in the
water but then something happened that
bestowed henry the reputation as one of
the greatest military commanders in
english history with his army decimated
the king was forced to abandon his plan
of attacking paris instead henry wanted
to march to calais and retreat to
england to regroup the french of course
had no intention of letting him leave
quietly they saw their opportunity to
crush their foe and they were absolutely
going to take it they met the english
army at agincourt
there is no definitive source on the
size of the french army some claim
twelve thousand others all the way up to
thirty thousand suffice to say that it
was significantly larger than what henry
was working with so the french military
leaders regarded this fight as a mere
bagatelle on october 25 1415 henry
proved them very very wrong let's start
with the battlefield although we're not
sure of the exact location of the battle
witness account said that henry lured
the french army into the narrowest
section of the field wedged between two
wooded areas in order to make it hard
for them to maneuver movement was also
heavily impeded by thick and slippery
mud caused by heavy rains there knowing
that the french had a strong cavalry
henry erected a row of sharp stakes in
front of his soldiers to stop the
enemy's charge finally he employed his
secret weapon the longbow in past
battles the english longbow had proven
to be devastatingly effective so the
french knights had no choice but to wear
heavy armor that was thick enough to
stop the arrows from piercing through
the battle that was supposed to be a
gimme for the french soon turned into an
absolute bloodbath the rank and file
soldiers were swiftly decimated by the
neverending hail of arrows whereas the
heavily armored men at arms were
exhausted from moving through the muddy
terrain and those who fell down found it
almost impossible to get up again indeed
a large part of the french army had not
been killed by sharp english steel but
by being suffocated in the mud or
getting trampled by friendly forces when
it was all said and done henry stood
triumphant next to a giant pile of
corpses that numbered up to 6 000
frenchmen whereas he only lost a few
hundred soldiers himself it was an
overwhelming victory any way that you
looked did it henry still didn't have an
army big enough to take full advantage
of it instead he returned to england
where he was greeted as a hero and began
making preparations for a new invasion
in early 1417 henry was ready to travel
to france again this time there were no
hair-raising skin-of-the-teeth moments
instead the king preferred a systematic
series of sieges of strategically
important cities on his way to paris it
took a lot longer and was nowhere near
as exciting but it was effective
nonetheless by 1419 henry had taken
cannes normandy and rule and paris
seemed like an inevitability he was
aided by the fact that the french were
dealing with their own internal strifes
and struggles for power just because
they had a common enemy did not mean
that all the various french fractions
played nice with each other quite the
opposite in fact the duke of burgundy
one of the most powerful men in the
country favored a diplomatic treaty with
henry because of this he was
assassinated in 1419 by his enemies and
his son philip the good allied himself
with england and helped negotiate a
treaty between henry and charles vi the
king of france
[Music]
on may 21 1420 england and france signed
the treaty of troy's charles the sixth
disinherited his eldest son the default
charles vii and married his daughter
catherine of valois to henry who became
the new regent of france and had his
bloodline recognized as a rightful
successor to the french throne in other
words charles was allowed to remain king
while he lived but once he bit the dust
the crown owed to henry or his sons on
paper henry had accomplished his goals
however he knew that actually getting
the treaty enforced was another matter
because there was an ongoing power
struggle in france some factions had
allied themselves with the dothran and
some kept fighting the english hoping to
reinstate charles the seventh of the
year they even brought in the scottish
on their side since they were always
down to kill a few englishmen this left
henry no choice but to return to france
in 1429 for his third military campaign
this one however would prove to be his
last at first things went well henry
once again adopted the safest strategy
of prolonged sieges until his opponent
surrendered but just like at half-life
dysentery swept through the english camp
and the king himself fell prey to its
noxious clutches ultimately it wasn't
the arrows or swords of his enemies that
befell king henry v but a lethal illness
which took his life suddenly on august
31 1422 henry was only 35 years old at
the time of his death and he was quickly
followed by the french king who died two
months later this meant that his infant
son henry vi became the new king of
england and france but as you might
expect a lot of people weren't too keen
on the idea so the hundred years war
resumed once more so i hope you enjoyed
today's video quick plug here at the end
if you enjoyed today's biographics which
has a lot of war content in it then i
imagine you're going to like my new
channel wara graphics where we do this
sort of thing but it's all about wars
exclusively check it out there's a link
below or just search youtube for war or
graphics and you'll be fine
see you next time
[Music]
you